so this one I'm actually gonna ask you
to write this up in your book because
we're going to use it in a second
actually need you to have it here work
because you're going to do something
physical to it in a second let's just
get these numbers down and as you do so
I'm going to walk through what is you're
looking at this is another way to
represent a set of Scots just like we
got one same idea but it just gives us a
finer sense of detail okay so the idea
here is that you'd look it together at
the stamp and leave you read them
simultaneously to get this so let's look
at the very first one the stamp starts
with one and then is a zero so I 1 is
here together what is that like so these
are actually um tens digits of these are
all units I'm you can see just below
here is 10 11 12 but when you put the 10
together with a 0 if you group them in
sequence and let me just come back to
you can see yeah I can do the same
calculation that you perform of range do
all of them on this as well and some
soup range just as we were just recently
not doing there
what's the top school what's the very
highest language there yeah it's gonna
be there for and the 90th so 49 so 49
that's top I'm gonna subtract my mother
school which is just 10 so my range in
this case will be 49 take away 10 that's
gonna be very good mode we know how to
find that that's the most common image
frequent school how
which one comes up most often about 1833
so I see a whole lot of 3t but I'm just
going to pay attention to the fact that
all of these leaves right all of these
leaves attached to this step so that's
why I'm not reading this 23 or 43 so we
looked at the range we looked at the
moment the other thing which is the
trickiest the most time-consuming finder
being here
so to find the median we're either going
to cross off stuff
are we going to count mine okay let it
cross things off and I wish you watch
them more closely and how about to do
this is just put your pen down for a
minute it's okay if you don't finish I'm
just going to a cross off but I want you
to ever wonder with me why I what I'm
about to do is wrong and I'm showing it
to you because some of these things do
it watch carefully
I'm going to cross off from the top and
then the bottom now I'm not finished yet
not finished yet but can someone tell me
what's problematic about this particular
way about going I'm not going to find
the median if I do this yeah cause if
you lose you give me a few really good
class today
krishana jump what do you think
[Music]
okay sir
if you didn't quite hear what I said the
first time right I've got to get the
biggest values from the top and then
we're going to get the smallest values
from the bottom do you agree with that
now if you have a look at this moment
right here that one I did have I crossed
off the top two values yeah look
carefully
have I crossed off the top two days I
have haven't you told me to Thomas 1:9
the next one thought that was 45 yet
thumbs up but have I crossed off the two
bottom that the answer's no because I
started looking from the top of here and
I went down so I she should start from
the left going to the right so my way
the piece this should look like now to
bring out now about the water to cross
down is that okay and I could keep on
going
can we maybe do this together you can
help me wake up I get it right but top
what is taught so far so good
follow me top bottom top bottom top no
yes yeah those are all the same this
bottom tall am I done
yeah so I found I think that which we
also found the mode that should be the
median 33 so far so good
okay one last thing before I sit you to
work checking the reading these one of
the reasons why so nicely
one of the reasons why we you might
think why do we introduce these two
things together like don't pots and
seven minutes
I usually think that because I didn't
realize how much they have in common so
this is a sterile epoch just like the
one you saw before right so you can see
here I've got a step above zero so that
might be that's my tens unit so this is
what just is seven by itself and I have
20 21 21 again and so on the reason why
we look at these two things together
steadily plants and dot plots is they're
actually kind of if you look at them the
right way and this by the way is why I
asked you to draw this in your walk
can you take your book and do what I'm
about to do now this is why you had to
do it you won't even have any that's all
right
how do what you got this is a dot plot
just with extra details filled in and we
can count through it exactly the same
way that you counted through it for does
that make sense so in fact if you look
at it for the right angle
don't focus on the stem-and-leaf plus
they're really kind of just the same
thing with different levels of detail
right to say whatever questions you this
one says mrs. listen I'm gonna 2015 but
it's slow it seemed really nice and it
is what does that also look like : grass
doesn't it and that's not a coincidence
so when you're doing these especially if
you struggle with being super neat
notice what mr. Weaver drew up his Emily
plot all the first leaves are together
all the seconds leaves are together
that's not a coincidence if you draw
them up fairly easily
you have another special type of display
which is not quite a common breath but
for now with all of that until we get
some more words in a couple of those
times but being neat and making sure
they will line up whether they do dots
or numbers is actually really helpful
for you this is a steep point this out
you can see my ones right see my ones
how they kind of conspicuously spaced
out
even though normally if you write once
you can write it really close together
the reason why I had to say semesters I
had to leave space for other numbers
like three in my directly beneath those
ones and zeros by five and directly
beneath those ones so that's why I've
learned to live with a space it out and
the textbook will do the same thing for
you okay